hey guys my name is Jess it is the 19th
of July and here's the latest in video
games Batman fans haven't you gained to
be pumped up about today as telltale
have revealed the first trailer and
launch date for the new episodic series
centered around the dark knight batman
the telltale series will let you control
both Bruce Wayne and his alter-ego
Batman the trailer also features some
familiar faces like Alfred Pennyworth
Harvey Dent Vicki Vale Jim Gordon and
Catwoman if you're all hyped up after
watching that one you won't be waiting
long to play it as the first episode
will arrive on pc ps4 xbox one 360 and
ps3 as well as iOS and Android devices
on august to the publisher are planning
to release the full season this year
although this is more of a hope going to
promise currently and there will also be
a physical version that other pokemon
game pokemon sun and moon is getting new
pokemon and while none of them are as
dynamic or interesting as the set of
keys and bag of trash that were
introduced in earlier editions is what
there is to look forward to the six new
pokemon who've been announced include
wimp odd the bug water-type pokemon who
lives in the state and has the ability
to wimp out and run away from battle
found sweet a grass-type who smells so
good people keep them in their houses
yes this is from the official
description comfy a fairy type who
adorably pics flowers and soothe sick
people and pokemon in hospitals the
ground type muds Dale who sounds like a
really really tough luck but a host
version for some reason then there's
mimic you a ghost fairy type who you
will either find super cute or
terrifying and has a disguise ability to
escape danger and finally beware you
guessed it this normal fighting pokemon
is a bear it gives bear house sun and
moon reaches the Pokemon Global Link
service as well as online and live
friendly competitions there's also a
hyper training function where you can
boost the power level of a level 100
Pokemon which wasn't possible in part
games for more details on all these bits
and pieces head to our story on games
but finally Square Enix of announced
that rise of the Tomb Raider will come
to PlayStation 4 on October 11 the 20
year celebration edition will include a
completely new story chapter called
blood time on top of that it will
feature co-op insurance game play
playstation vr support for the new
chapter or previously released dlc new
outfits weapons and expedition curves
you'll also be able to get stuck into a
zombie killing mode called Lara's
nightmare where you must defend Croft
manner and there's a new extreme
survivor difficulty a limited edition
art book is also included this content
will be made available to xbox one and
pc players for free who already have the
season pass although you will miss out
on the VR support do stop by games watch
where we've got stories on Destiny's new
expansion and injustice to and show to
come by again tomorrow for a bunch more
news